as a nation we are experiencing a
significant increase in drug overdose
deaths
the dea and pact coalition partner up
twice a year to give communities a
chance to help stop this
here's more information on this month's
pill take back day
so pill take back day april 24th what
does that mean what is this concept of
pill
take back so what we're doing is
we partner with the dea and a bunch of
other agencies
in town twice a year to do a big roundup
of all the unused medication
what we know is people will leave
unused medication in their medicine
cabinet and sometimes
kids and other people can go in and take
that and
we want to uh discourage
diversion of all of these medications
into
unsafe uses so tell us about the event
and how people um can get involved
it's going to be saturday april 24th
from 10 a.m to 2 p.m
and we have multiple locations this year
um
we have we have about six locations
and we tried to put them in in different
areas where
it made it more accessible for people in
the community to be able to to make it
to one of the locations
we have we have a location over at the
henderson police station
at 300 south green valley parkway we
have one
at the north las vegas northwest area
command over at 3755
west washburn we have one at the las
vegas metropolitan police department
northwest area command and we also have
one at the
northeast area command we also have two
locations
um smith's uh and walmart are partners
with us as well
with pac coalition wow so no excuses
you guys are covering the valley that's
great um so what should people
not bring to the event what what is not
accepted
um so the what we don't we don't like to
take
are needles um and we also
we have alternatives for for properly
disposing of any type of needles
but not not for take back event and
aerosols and
and liquids we would like to avoid
taking as well just because
for the disposal process it it's not
good so
we we only take the prescription drugs
that if you bring them in bottles that's
fine um just
make sure you mark out your name and any
type of
patient information we may not be able
to take it but we can definitely tell
you where to dispose of it if we need to
what we are seeing is we are seeing an
increase in overdose deaths um in 2020
we
saw a significant spike and if we can
divert
all of these unused medications if we
can um stop the first time
someone uses a drug that they got from
someone else's medicine cabinet
we can definitely prevent this problem
before it becomes
an issue and isn't that what we're all
here to do is make our community safer
and this is the easiest way you can do
so just dispose of your unused
medication
there's two different websites that you
can go to it's one is
drugfreelasvegas.org
and then the other is
takebackday.dea.gov and
there it's more of a national
location search finder so if you're if
you're wanting to tell your family
members
in different states they can look at
that as well
that is great make sure you spread the
word the next pill take back day is
april 24th from 10 a.m to 2 p.m
and there will be drop-off locations
across the valley you can head to
drugfree lasvegas.org
for more information we'll be right back